everybody hold your shirts up yeah yeah
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
we're gonna get started here I'm just
gonna do an intro while everybody's
doing this freestyle so welcome to
another episode of Black Ice reality
check I'm your host Black Ice we have a
great group of people uh people people
so what you did to me yeah
we have the one and only hated by most
loved by some okay my mom likes me a lot
the whales don't so damn we have Pearl
all the way from London is that fair
yeah from Chicago Yeah well yeah London
London are you here yet are you gonna be
here well soon I gotta I gotta figure
out what city so I'm checking out Vegas
this week see I'm gonna get dude West
Coast Connection West Coast represent
Death Row Records no I'm just kidding
West Coast baby we got Troy's in the
house from London we did an intro
earlier but we're gonna do a second one
all right Born James Bond London right
Daniel Craig his name's Francis yeah man
thank you for having me thank you for
having me on it's a privilege and a
pleasure to be here and it's These Guys
these guys English accents are some of
the best I think
country London you know
yeah it's [__] up I'm probably gonna
like imitate you the whole podcast thing
I'm looking forward
like why do we have that in the middle
right there like what do you love him
his name is good dick oh God wait wait
wait wait wait it's cold outside oh my
God
don't get excited don't get excited no
I've never seen that I've never seen a
penis no I've never seen like uh
good I'm good okay we got Kristen in the
house yes you were calling me the female
Alex Jones and here you are with your
little supplement line
three Alpha
man it's bad I'm gonna get it back hey
if Joe Rogan can do it I can do it
absolutely we got David in the house all
the way from Seattle area Washington my
hometown which is wild no one's ever
from Seattle but here we are and I know
where Monroe is Monroe Minho whatever
you want to call it never heard
I guess
what do you guys know about Monroe
there's like one road Highway two wait
well no it's 5 22.
go out there you pass a prison I see
that Prison from my back I have the
whole view I face South and I can see
all the mountains and every night it's a
little bit of a Christmas tree the
prison and then you go to this little
town that was set up because of a place
called gold bar where the gold mining
town is oh yeah so back in the Golden
Days the gold rush on the way to Alaska
right Monroe it's beautiful yeah it's
nice what's the nightlife like
banjos and they got a racetrack there
that's all I got there yeah a racetrack
in a Walmart
yeah
we have these in multiple colors guys
I do I do agree with this because a lot
of the problems in society stem from the
fact that women are crazy liberal and
they voted and caused a lot of this
[__]
where does that come from it comes from
propaganda early 1900s they realize that
women are dummies and they realize they
could just show us a video of some 12
year old that can't get an abortion and
we're like oh my God is she emotional
there's a difference between the first
way of feminism and no no they were all
terrorists they planned assassinate but
the second wave was when
abortional happened no I think it was
always freedom without it
so what I'm here for you're in
conversations
I would I I agree that 80 of women don't
know [__] about so I'm a
computer she has a podcast I've been a
lot of comedian uh a business owner I'm
a business owner yes I have I have my
own business where I do window repair
and I install interior doors and I make
solar screens for Las Vegas which is why
she's so ripped all the time and then we
have Coco married to the red pill Coco
yeah Federal podcast and or I'm gonna
give props out to Glenn Lawrence by the
way Glenn is like brings everybody
together he really did yeah Glenn is
like
um
um you know another one what's his name
DJ Khaled of the red pill podcasting
Network he connects all the podcasters
together so give it up for Glenn
Lawrence I'll put them in the
description box so we are here with
pearl Pearl we got some questions for
you okay so so we we talked about the
women shouldn't vote shirt yes what is
that about what's your push there is
that a cause you're pushing or is that
just a I know I seriously I think all of
the world's problems would be solved if
we didn't vote Yes you would ban voting
for women globally
how do you feel about I agree with you
for the most part but in a blanket world
how do you feel about the Middle East
and the women who get stoned to death
for not wearing their burqa and wanting
just basic education and basic rights
how do you feel about that in in
comparison to the to the right to not
vote because I agree with you most women
don't know [__] about politics so a lot
of men don't either I know well the
difference is the men have like
something there's more in the game they
do women are more influenced by their
surroundings they're more malleable so
so I understand what you're saying
everything is it makes complete so the
Middle East I don't know to be honest I
don't know much about the Middle East
I'm not a Middle East expert but what I
will say is I do think that there is
propaganda where they kind of push that
these women just have these horrible
lives and and I just kind of noticed the
same patterns so I have a tough time
believing that they're just these
oppressed people hey I was just in
Istanbul and they were they're wearing
their burqas with Yeezys on so I don't
know yeah
it's pretty it's pretty liberal over
there isn't it yeah
like my brother is Muslim he was in the
military here he saw how the Middle East
was living and was like oh my God the
West is totally [__] up I just want a
traditional woman I want to become
Muslim I'm going to grow my beard out
I'm gonna move to the Middle East and he
did that well that's why these guys are
moving to Dubai isn't it yeah like
Dubai's becoming yeah but that's more
that's more like the westernized the
Muslim culture it's more it's more so
what I'm saying when it comes to women's
rights
I agree for the most part women should
just give over their
right
to vote to the head of household and say
you know what you're doing but please at
least listen to what I have to say
because if I do know what I'm talking
about somebody like me who does know
what's happening in the world I have no
problem with not voting but I want my
husband to hear me out at least whereas
in the Middle East a lot of those places
you're not even allowed to speak about
those things what places
Pakistan Afghanistan
those women in Pakistan and Afghanistan
one of the leading causes of death for
women is being stoned yes okay I have a
hard time believing that but okay yes a
lot of those women are stoned okay
that a majority that die you're gonna
stand on there are still a lot of women
who do is it the top reason that they
like is this is this that common
I I think it's more common than it is
anywhere else in the world right no but
I'm saying there's a difference between
there being like Fringe cases and it
being super common yeah like you know
what I mean there's a difference between
like okay this Fringe thing happened
versus this is happening everywhere this
is common for the women I think so but I
think at the end of the day women are
very it's heart disease
pretty much
how do you feel about it how do you feel
about a woman always men have always
listened to women men are benevolent
dictators the truth of the matter is
when men get power in general they're
pretty nice and when they're not nice
usually other men come in and kick their
ass and kill them
I agree with that and typically like you
know I think men are meaner to other men
than to women I agree with that too yeah
when women and women
[Laughter]
because I had a question on that because
you guys are saying um that women
shouldn't vote if women can't vote do
you guys still agree with them being in
our military no no I don't think a woman
should be close to the military no she
should be as I don't even agree with a
woman being a nurse in the military well
and then all the women in the military
start [__] all the guys and then
they're like
well they'll get like raped it's like me
too well they also have a special
treatment that men don't get because I
have to accommodate for their period
they're now accommodating if they're
actually getting pregnant when they're
in the military and it's like men don't
have that luxury is going to pay for
that you're nine months of being great
for them to modify their uniform so they
can't hold them
you also can't really trust any of this
like rape anymore because they switched
the definition of rape it used to be
forced sex and now it's sex without
consent so you can basically like get
into bed with a guy yeah and then like
oh he raped me even though I like went
home with him and then I said rape turns
into transgender like like well that's
fantastic I just feel that he raped me
so well yeah well yeah because sexist or
consent is subjective and so that's what
the feminists do they get into these
institutions and they change definitions
and they can also now retroactively like
take someone to call like I saw a case
the other day where this guy this woman
was trying to Sue this dude because she
was saying well when I had sex with him
he said he was going to marry me
wait wait
what happened we used to take L's and
move on like you didn't you didn't go
around well thank you
and you wouldn't want to tell everyone
about it because it's a little
embarrassing you just go home and eat
ice cream and cry about it watch a sad
movie and then move on yeah it's like we
got to tell everyone and start a cork
just take your owl David you've been no
so you've been married the whole time
since you've since day one when you
first were with a woman married the
whole time so you haven't been exposed
to the dating scene or outside y'all are
freaking wild I'm just gonna say that
right now like I don't I I look at the
stuff from the outside so crazy story I
lost my virginity to my wife we've been
together since 2014. we started dating
July of 2014 proposed to her in January
2015 got married in August 2015 and
we're about to come on eight years of
marriage one woman my entire life but if
you can meet how did you meet your
school or college or so my mom actually
introduced me to her daddy mutual friend
at a birthday party so no it wasn't even
arranged I'm just playing it was more so
it was there's a mutual friend she was a
gossiper and so my that friend watched
her grow up and so when they all met my
mom told me about her I was dating some
girl at the time she didn't like and she
showed me one picture of her if you ever
look her up on Instagram gorgeous it's
just at Yanna fish Chuck and she had
these like striped pants on and I was
like oh those legs don't end
so I followed her I was dating this girl
or else the process is breaking up with
her and I like asked the this this
mutual friend about her and not one kind
of thing aside from just the fact that
her the parents were split and there was
just some stuff going on there now would
she was she in Monroe no she was in
Auburn which is okay it's an hour away
yeah it's a road trip every time I went
to go date and see each other yeah in
Seattle I mean here you get there in 15
minutes there it takes you eight hours
to drive not literally but it's traffic
right forget it so yeah it's like going
through London from one end to the other
yeah yeah right so do I say like I told
my wife I was like there is no like we
we got into the relationship knowing
that we wanted to get married early and
grow together and was she a virgin too
yeah oh wow and I talk about rare that's
what I'm like yo I never want to break
up with their loser anything because I
have to go back to the dating pool
so much work it's not even as fun as I
like when I was because you're what
mid-20s I'm 29 yeah late 20s mid to late
20s when I was in it's like
it was a little bit more fun and
exciting now it's just dreads I mean I'm
terrified
tally whacker down there don't you that
terrifies me I'm like you don't even
know you don't even know so I'm like
wait wait did you say tell me what do
you mean Daniel Craig over here so it's
like you know I got the extra equipment
that is basically that's what I'm afraid
of that's why I'm like you come to Vegas
and it's like you don't know what you're
gonna get you're done Pearl when you
remember we were talking about on your
podcast how how there's no virgins out
there or it's hard to find a virgin or
men don't want to what are your thoughts
on men should they have to be with a
virgin to be successful in a marriage or
what are your thoughts on this well only
nine I think 96 of women aren't virgins
on their wedding days 96 yeah so good
luck if you want one like they don't
really exist it's so funny because it's
like all the women will come forward and
like you know it's like we're all [__]
all of us because yeah no 90s no no
seriously because 96 of us will be
thrown out a hundred years ago yeah I
got a one percent wife I'm cool with it
how do we not know that maybe they're
not married like she's not a virgin on
their wedding day but maybe she only had
sex with that guy
ninety percent like it's like okay okay
we'll give another another five but it's
still nine out of ten of us would be
thrown out a hundred years ago so I mean
can men expect that in 2023 it I don't
say this happily you know but not really
well then when you have a social media
life that is brought on to 20 something
year old women who are at the age of
insecure their marriage and insecurities
they're going to Veer themselves into a
a pond that maybe they're not even in to
like all of these women who are going
into uh
uh
selling their bodies
one out of 25 under the age of 35 cells
oh I'm sure I'm sure I want to talk
about that I want to talk about it I
would think it's even more than that
you're like this well yeah that's just
caminals but my philosophy is mental was
pay for it yup yeah and that's why when
there's dollars is one out of 25 selling
or or all of them I think it's more than
that if you're married you're paying for
it if you're married you have to have
resources you if you have a girlfriend
you have to resources you're dating
hookers if you have a transactional
relationship you're paying for it so
maybe one out of 25 has a transactional
situation but I believe all men pay and
the guys that don't just like a guy says
I'd never pay for it oh she did it for
free well I wouldn't want to be with a
girl that's free because that that
there's no value if she says oh come
over and watch Netflix and we'll have
sex dude that's easy like who wants to
be with that so look at it from this
perspective if for thousands of years
men or women always went for guys with
resources right yeah Dr David Buss in
his book uh evolution of desire and if
that's the case we have to establish
those resources that costs us money I
think there's a distinction though
between uh paying for it and just being
a guy who's of you know decent Network a
decent net worth and he can he can
provide interesting experiences like
I've talked to the Tates about this I
talked to no there is I talked to
Tristan about this and and and and they
had have or had a lot of money right and
he would date women and he said but it's
not like it's not like you say to the
woman right come out and I'm gonna you
know I'll give you five grand for the
weekend it's not that but but it is hey
I've got this cool car we can take a
trip we go down to Italy we'll be by the
beach we'll go to this cool restaurant
blah blah blah so they're providing the
money allows you to provide an
interesting
experience but it's not necessarily but
I agree there are degrees of
transactionality in all of this stuff
but that that you don't have to be you
know Tristan textile multi-millionaire
for that to happen though they're on a
on a lower level there's a lot of girls
who they want to go on trips they're you
know I think I think the whole point is
that you know just as women we make kind
of dumb decisions so here put that up
again please
you know and no that's what I was
thinking about I'm like yeah it's better
like and I was thinking about I was
thinking about how nowadays like under
five is the new version and I was
thinking about how sad that is I'm like
well as a group I'm like as a group like
the best women in today's market it's
like under five well the best women of
today's market know that the the thing
of women shouldn't vote our whole system
is rigged to [__] begin with anyway
and any woman of value is gonna go
it doesn't even matter what's a woman of
value a woman of value knows Harry's one
of these rounds
I'd say high value is a virgin everyone
else may be somewhere medium value but
there's no such thing as a high valued
woman I think nowadays
imagine so if you're well that's a
quality I think it's an energy that you
give off I think if you value yourself
and you're probably gonna go oh here she
goes again saying as she gets older she
gets more beautiful and that's [__]
but if you have an energy about you and
you present yourself to the world like I
am a high value woman not in a fake way
what if you're 300 pounds and you have
less energy yeah that's what I'm
thinking I don't think that you will
have that energy about you because you
are 300 pounds why are there 300 pounds
that's the question like why is it
better shape than I was when I was 24.
so I have that energy about me at 37
because I'm in bed
I do do you consider yourself like the
top 10 20 of women I would say the top
30. okay top 30 because when I think of
like I mean we could say quality
and even even do doing that but but
someone are better than others right we
got it we gotta kind of know them that
has to do with my intellect but there's
yeah but that's how it looks yeah
there's a rule in the exception right so
the looks and this is what yeah I saw
you responded that post and I get it
yeah when I said feelings it's like if I
ask a woman how she rates herself she's
like well I didn't even write my no no
no no I know but I say I feel I'm a I'm
a eight or a nine or a 10. this or that
and it's like no your looks just your
looks yeah and then they start giving
you this long answer I didn't give you a
lot I'm not talking about you the group
of girls I didn't give myself an eight
and or nine or ten
that's like 30 I didn't even do that and
all I'm saying is I gain knowledge as I
got older and that that benefits
it's like no I'm serious I'm serious
like think about this I want a girl that
knows a lot
[Music]
if I meet a girl who knows a lot I'm
like [__] red flag man I just like
scratch that water scratch that one off
well my thing is yeah but would you be
would long term
exactly that's where men
think exactly go ahead
because I'm saying you you think you're
smarter or you think you're wiser and uh
as the time has gone on yes as you've
gotten older you think you're worth it
guys aren't gonna think what like why
would a guy think you're worth it
without your opinion but that's the
exception without your opinion because
that's your opinion of yourself is one
thing against someone else so clearly
something is working that look at the
rig as well no but
that's also objective to each individual
man
that's subjective in a sense where
divorce rates are still high of course
so Troy I got a question so of course
when you're when you're coaching man
that are oh go ahead oh and I was gonna
say over the age of 35 you only have
like a 15 chance of getting down the
aisle yeah so like you you could be the
exception but you're not the rule I
don't totally understand yeah yeah and I
I agree with that so Troy when you're
coaching and mentoring these guys and
dating
um do you run into this a lot with these
guys looking for these pretty women and
the challenges they're having and what
they're running into because what I'm
seeing now no no what I'm what I'm
seeing now is the scales adjusted with
time now because of all the attention
from the social media that we're seeing
yeah right the female attention
necessity disorder that coin phrase
right that none of the the psychologists
will take but all the attention they're
getting they're so used to attention
when the pandemic hit everybody had
these mental disorders because they
weren't getting the attention outside so
they got them online and I'm an eight
I'm a ten I'm a ten yeah and then they
don't date anybody because all because
there's only a few percentage of guys
that have that ability I think I think
there's a few things I think yeah
overall I think it's become it's become
tougher I think it's become flakier you
know even if you're talking to a girl on
a dating app or you meet her in the
coffee shop or whatever then yeah you
know you should definitely gonna come
out and meet you or maybe she you know
the next bright shiny object comes along
but on the other hand these girls still
want to meet people they still want to
get laid do you know what I mean I think
it also gets a little I think it'll hell
yeah
I think it gets a little bit overstated
as well I mean you could still go out
there and make things happen but equally
there's a lot of distractions for these
women and you know that there is an
element of this stuff happening for sure
you know if she's getting hit up by you
know the bloke with the the yacht
the bloke the geyser with the yacht in
Miami
and then she's you know that's gonna
color her sense of her own values about
it well and I realized too that like
we're basically like men addicted to
porn all of us with social media
women are basically also addicted to
social media it's like the equivalent of
a guy addicted to totally and I know
this because it's like and I see the
propaganda working firsthand because I
like talk to girls on my show and it's
like they all say the same thing they
don't even know what they're saying yeah
like even like like when I think of
horoscope it's like what are we doing
why are we talking about it's funny too
because I found myself desensitized to
to Instagram when Instagram first came
out it was like way back in 07 or
something or 05 and it was a few
pictures oh nine I think it was I
remember seeing I posted a picture and
now it became this real thing but I
remember when the reels kicked off you
you'd go to your search bar if you go to
all your search bars you're like whoa
look at this chick look at this chick
now I see it I'm like oh my God you're
so desensitized to it whereas in ten
years ago you'd have been popping a
party in two seconds to it right
[Applause]
it's all done on purpose so and that's
to be popular well don't you respect
that we're we're depopulate us there's a
depopulation agenda happening and they
do not want people procreating with one
another what's the problem with the
foreign
which is crazy right yeah but they they
will want that but they're also going to
probably take robots right but my whole
thing is like they're doing that because
women have these crazy high standards
but that's all an agenda but I I
understand it's an agenda but I don't I
think like we're disagreeing on like how
it started like I'm saying women have
these high standards the men are sexless
so they go to porn what's a response to
us real quick David what would you do if
you were single right now single right
now I'd Focus solely on becoming the
best version of yourself this is what I
do in my life so I'm affiliate marketer
but my main thing I'm doing now is I'm a
life coach I get guys discipline with
their mind body and spirit specifically
like my biggest advice as well this
whole topic was porn that was like the
one thing in my life I was married in
watching porn wife didn't even know
about it and there was a disconnect in a
relationship I stopped a year ago
correct right I stopped a year ago and I
waited three four months before I
started coaching anybody until I could
heal myself yeah I told my wife that and
she said that's why we that's why I
thought you didn't think I was
attractive no she's bomb the problem was
the problem was I was desensitized like
you said yeah I didn't think it was bad
I would always use it as a crutch just
like oh I'm so busy with business with
work I just go like rub one off don't
even think about it and then I saw like
how messed up it was I was like
withholding in a weird way I was talking
to Glenn about it yesterday I was like I
use it as like a withholding method I
didn't even realize it yeah and as soon
as I stopped officially like I could
walk into a room like in Vegas I don't
get swayed at all I feel like I'm in a
certain it's crazy certain realm it's so
crazy how you walk down the street here
I was like they're allowed to just have
their boobs out I don't even I don't
even pay them it's weird we're waiting
for you to do that
I was just like I was walking down the
street I would say pearl just do that oh
my God I got spanked today by one of
those [__] I swear to God I was I
would tell you
you're trying to give me the Handcuff
thing and I was like uh no this [__]
spanks me when I walk by and I'm like
what the [__]
so the question was was your face like
this was like whoa
you're just like this man though men
need way more discipline in their life
they have to get aligned like I said
mind body and spirit it all starts with
Fitness Nutrition getting dialed in with
your with with your body anytime you
walk in the room you see a man who's
jacked you can trust that man right away
in a way of the disciplined realm
because it takes a lot of discipline to
do that and then it stems out from there
go either way there's a lot of immature
douchey guys that are fit correct but I
use it as a method to lead into a
mindset where if you have a vice like
alcohol like porn like drugs like
gambling it all starts with a discipline
where if you can be disciplined for
three months straight six months
straight be dialed in you can create a
body of your dreams and all of a sudden
you start going well how do I actually
stop the alcohol I just say when you
wake up every morning you murder the old
version of yourself and you chase the
elite version of yourself and my whole
thing was as soon as I was able to hear
myself from the point I don't care about
it I'll walk by Vegas one of these guys
was like you're going to Vegas I was
like dude you're married I'm like yeah
but you're talking to some
it's all about it's about discipline
it's about becoming the best version of
yourself it's about chasing chasing
Excellence yeah however however if guys
also want to get [__] they've also got
to study that side of things they've got
to make sure their games
is on point because if it isn't you know
because sometimes guys think okay I'm
just gonna get you know I'm gonna get
ripped I'm gonna get money I'm gonna get
you blah blah blah and the women are
just gonna come to me but unfortunately
the world that we live in you know you
need to have that a bit of that edge to
you as well don't you 100 you know and
you're in a great position man because
you've obviously you know you're you're
in a position that many guys would envy
because you yeah but the biggest problem
is selling coaching on dating is easier
because guys like you said all men want
[__] but the thing is to convince
someone who is skinny fat or overweight
or someone just wants to level up in
life yeah to be like hey the only way
that you can actually achieve that is if
you really truly want to change you
can't force somebody to eat clean for
three months straight six months
straight you have to want it and in a
society of weak men while I do is on
Instagram look at AI girls jerk off 24
7. don't want to go out and date in the
real world then you get woman like you
woman in here just like there's no guys
out there yeah there's no guys because
all the girls want the better guys
you're right though about wanting it
isn't it that's to make any change in
your life it's about do you have that
[__] strong desire to have the thing
and a lot of guys don't and even with
the dating stuff right you'd be amazed I
mean guys
how can a guy interact with a woman
without a legal consequence
ask me that question I just have the one
wife so I don't have to worry about
anything
I'm blessed
but even men with wives have legal
consequences all the time I said too I
was like babe I would never Chill on you
why I don't want to deal with the BS
involved in divorce yeah yeah but I'm
saying like like I think you know a lot
of times we we go on to the men for
walking away from women but it's like
there's no way for them to interact with
women without their being a legal
consequence for example there are men
that get kicked out of gyms for looking
at women did you see that story about
then the trans can come into our locker
rooms on the flip side like she said I
was good about that dude who was blind
and he was looking at a woman and she
was like oh my God you're so creepy and
she complained you got kicked out the
Germany I saw that actually blind but
you know what's funny I said that I said
that or he was blind
[Applause]
I said that's crazy I said that to a guy
and he's like oh I know like three guys
that happened to it it's like you start
to get like message like when you start
doing what I do you just get so many
messages of guys saying like I had this
interaction
there is a lot of [__] that happens I
think I mean I don't know touch you with
man I mean the problem we've got certain
certain places are bad certain places
the solution hold on hold on
there you go certain places are really
are really bad for this I mean obviously
we're in London so you got that you've
got the United States I think it was
super super woke all that kind of stuff
there are other countries where this
stuff is less prevalent I will say in a
market cities the big cities in the US
is really bad that's why I tell men when
they're they're asking about where I
should meet women I don't date women in
a markets yeah I'm sure I agree my
girl's from the Sea Market a little town
right yeah and so I don't know what your
philosophy is that so I was talking
about Regional dating overseas no big
cities well you're coaching men on
dating I'm gonna I'm gonna lead it with
you Troy when you're when they're asking
where do you meet women what are you
saying to them because I'm finding in
big cities it's a lose-lose situation
yeah so what are your thoughts on small
smaller towns spiders the best places
that we find because we go
internationally quite a lot so say we're
in Poland you've got Warsaw which is the
main overseas
overseas but even within within a
country so Warsaw is a capital city main
city and it is really great for David
yeah but equally what's quite good is to
go to the Second City or even the third
city in the country you know because
it's less it's more traditional it's
it's it's more traditional it's less
packed oh you look like you have
something yeah are you saying Western
women aren't the best
are you saying American women
[Music]
it's the nato-based countries where the
the like what I mean the nato-based
countries are the ones who are the most
corrupt and the ones who have the most
sex and the most westernized philosophy
so so if you go to Eastern Europe or you
go to Asia or you go to South Central
America yeah you have a better
opportunity as a man to find
I'd love to help you get disciplined
Mind Body Spirit become one of the
freaking men who's addicted to the
freaking porn the drugs the alcohol and
focus on I don't know sticking with one
woman that isn't freaking corrupt the
ones that actually understand that maybe
women shouldn't vote in all situations
because uh the world is crazy so I do
agree with you with a lot of that my
wife says the exact same thing I was
actually driving back home and I saw the
only black lives matter sticker that was
still left was a white liberal woman in
the car of course
love you guys have a great time
thank you so much wear that anywhere
take a pic tag me
how wonderful evening
girl maybe wear it
yeah Uber driver I was like did you
really yeah I totally did I was like do
you think women are smart enough to vote
and that he was like yeah I'm like we're
not here you go
[Laughter]
so so back to this uh topic um you're
telling me overseas and all these other
cultures and societies well so a lot of
guys that I work with I know
um came out of London and London's a
great City very big very International
there's a lot of people you know
beautiful women there whatever but as
far as the dating proposition is
concerned a lot of guys will end up
traveling okay so a lot of God and where
they will go will be the former Eastern
European countries the former Soviet
Union countries right and Latin America
and somewhat places like southeast Asia
as well but I I'm not really I sent like
30 guys over to Colombia so my Colombia
is is Colombia is so many guys problems
would be sold by getting on a plane and
going to Colombia man it's crazy
no no three of them now are are in these
long-term relationships it's worked out
great yeah yes it's phenomenal totally
they're [__] I have a question on
that another U.S Colombian girls
no no no
no no right
I am from a country like a small town I
grew up in Acton California and it's
very small very country everybody had
property like we understood
responsibility we had Traditional Values
because it was smaller it wasn't like we
didn't really venture out and go into
the cities unless we're going to the
beach okay so you have to do the import
where like my girl was born in Sonora
Mexico and then she came in when she was
eight Sonora Sonora is like the Border
it's a state of Mexico and he said it
like that it's the it's a state that's
uh south of uh Arizona right but she
came here and then Tucson is like a
tumbleweed Town there's nothing there oh
yeah
if you drive on the freeway and you
drive on the freeway hey we're in Tucson
oh cool
so that's how it actually so here's how
sheltered it is I meet her on Instagram
indirectly she had a food pic I'm like
looking at food right like guys don't
don't like hot chicks pics like yeah
there's another dude yeah and as you
start interacting and it's and when I
started getting to know her she's you
know she didn't really know what I did I
said I do this or that she's like oh you
pray well I said yeah I do over six
figures she goes what's six figures mean
I'm like
winner winner chicken dinner right
because I'm like high quality woman she
had no idea because in Tucson nobody
makes that and over there it's very you
know traditional or Mom raiser to be a
good wife her dad's like when you we get
married you make sure you cook for your
husband all this stuff and here's the
other thing ready for this
five is average she was cute six and
then she became a man I elevated her
game she became six seven and eight
right nice because you know she got
around it but here's the other thing she
didn't do she didn't expose herself to
external negative input like I said I
don't want to go to the club with these
girls you want to do that yeah and
here's what I did
I said you know what you want to go go
hang out with your girls go I don't want
to I want to be with you yeah I I told
her go ahead yeah yeah I gave her the I
took I want to say take the leash off
but I gave her the the expansion to do
what she wanted yeah and if she hung
herself she hung herself now I'm gonna
shift gears because me and Lana talked
about this earlier my friend am I
confident my battle buddy we butt heads
a lot but we love each other off the set
but we're like we do have like a like a
love-hate relationship let me tell you
that we have one one thing in common
that we all think
women
I totally agree with it
and they battled all day yeah and the
coyote tried to get the Sheep
the coyote tried to get the Sheep yeah
and and I was the Sheepdog protecting
right and then all of a sudden they
clocked out and they were friends that's
me and her yeah so here's the question
what were you battling about before it's
just it's just Dynamics in relationships
dating you know whatever we're good
friends but you know when you you know
you disagree we have very friendly
disagreements okay so we will have
heated discussions but we'll be like no
what the [__] no it's not like that and
then yeah so here's here's my topic I
want to talk about this we talked about
this I'm gonna go with pearl first what
are your thoughts of people in a
relationship or dating and the guy's
gonna date this girl they've been
talking and she says well I have a guy
friend but I'm not going to get rid of
my guy friend we're going to date
I mean girls do that all the time yeah
so what are your thoughts on that they
probably shouldn't do that why
um because guys are always trying to
[__] you know what I mean it's like
they're guys but do you think that's an
insecurity if a guy says I don't want
you to have your guy friend when we date
her is that a respect issue I think I
think you should respect him so I think
I think you're supposed to obey your
husband so I think you should but so she
has a choice you've said I won't date
you because I want to have my guy
friends so she has a choice what are
your thoughts on that
I mean so here's the thing right it
depends on the nature of the
relationship how you're going into that
relationship because because it's a deal
with me firstly I'm not particularly
looking for anything that serious at the
moment I tend to date around and even
and even when I let exactly
and even I think even if I was look you
know even if I was open to meeting
somebody longer term which I haven't in
the past or whatever
um what I generally do is I let them do
their thing like you were saying I watch
what they do and then I make a decision
on based on that if this is somebody
where this could gel or not so if I was
just randomly like kind of seeing
something like hooking up with some girl
and she's got a guy I don't really care
it doesn't matter right okay if if but
then if I was thinking well am I going
to consider this this woman as like a
serious something a bit more serious
like more serious partner then I'd be
thinking well hang on a minute this is a
bit of a red flag no uh I'm not really
you know I'm probably not into that now
we can talk about this open yeah so she
sure they were in a relationship I guess
you and your boyfriend just recently
broke up because of this guy friend
seriously yeah were you [__] the guy
no it wasn't it uh no never I've never
had sex with any of my guy friends but
like when when you get to know
when you get to know me I walk around
with a dick I really genuinely like in
my head I genuinely think I have a dick
so I'm one of the boys okay when you get
to know me you'll see because even he
says it I'm one of the boys so I have a
lot of male friends not very many female
friends because my female friends can't
handle a joke okay like a lot of females
cannot handle a joke and I joke too much
so when I'm around guys they're you know
they tend to be like I wouldn't [__] you
so what happened would that cause a
relationships
they wouldn't [__] I disagree with that
too you guys can disagree I actually
like I can call him right now and be
like hey
have you ever have you ever done it
before no ask them to have sex no no but
don't hold on for a year they will on
for years
you have to talk to him in a way that he
thinks it's serious yeah if you ask him
if he wants those but that's the thing
it's hard to do on a phone call right
like you're gonna call him hey do you
want to have sex with me they're like
what are you doing you know I was
thinking
for so long like why haven't we dated
I've always liked you no we've never
liked each other no no no that's who you
should say to him but are you but don't
you have an emotional connection me and
your friend okay so me and my friend I
call on my brother he calls me his
sister that's literally the dynamic I
introduced him to dabrick as my brother
and he believed it until I told him it
wasn't well but you did this is my
sister
but
even still you can tell when someone's
not their brother you can tell you're
just like it's a little flirty and so
what do you have to say so it's a little
flirty so it's a little flirty you just
but you just said it's a little flirty I
didn't say that about my relationship I
said that about others so me and my
brother are not Florida is is it
possible that he's a little bit into you
I'm curious what did you think did he
want to [__] well I just met him this
brother I said hey whatever like I mean
it took her word for granted but the
point is is that you had a phone call
with him right and he called and your
boyfriend so this was another guy
because I have multiple male friends
that's that's the issue is gonna want
that no guy is gonna want
the disagreement isn't this the
disagreement was I said she's and again
I'm not attacking Lana I was saying for
me it's a respect issue it's not an
insecurity but I also know how men are
yeah right and I have a choice she has a
choice we have a choice but when I met
when I met my gal she put herself in a
position to say you know what she didn't
have she goes she moved but she's like I
don't these are guys I grew up from high
school she cut communication so I don't
want to disrespect you and I let her
hang herself and she's going to hang
herself but I don't have the insecurity
but I know guys I'm a guy and we all
said I simped before I used to be that
guy back in the day I hung out with a
pretty girl
Dennis Rodman's ex-wife the basketball
player was a friend of mine we kind of
hung out his friends I sent I hung out
with the opportunity and then as I got
my game and my frame and my muscles and
my money and I figured the game out I
was like no I'm not doing that and we
can just hang on well first of all not
I'm not referring to Lana why do I want
to hang out with you I'm busy hustling
making money I'm dating somebody we can
be friends there's no value unless I'm
having sex with you I don't want to hang
out with you as a woman and so for me
Pearl's a friend from a distance we've
went to dinner with my girl with pearl I
will never disrespect girl but at the
same time I'm not going to go hey Pearl
let's go hang out let's go play
basketball she's yeah she's a woman I'm
a man I got tested I wake up with a
heart on I know it's like I might say
hey what are you doing come over watch
Netflix and chill I know what's going to
happen yeah I never asked that
she asked me the other night she was
here I'm at the hotel I'm in my Linda
right now I'm just kidding
and she goes she goes here's my Linda
Ray
I should get laundry
yeah
not the disrespect alone but for me I
have a different standard and so it
wasn't the guy as much as you're sharing
intimate conversations with this guy and
we're on a trip and he's calling you hey
hey buddy how's it going oh I'm here
we're having a good time it just feels
like I'm dating three people totally
it took me a long time to learn the
difference and I'm like you know it took
me 30 years to learn that yeah it did
yeah but the thing is like a lot of
times we share a private information
about a relationship and I just think
that you're sharing that with us
yeah and so it's like it's kind of
disrespectful and I'll turn I'll turn my
guys like my guy friends against my
boyfriend yeah
okay I'm like no no I have a question
like would you ever like change that if
you felt like it was getting the way of
you of you getting a partner or
boyfriend long time to become okay to be
completely Fair it's the reasoning
behind that is because my my guy friends
have done a lot more for me than a guy
boyfriend has had has done oh do you
want me to put the Shelf
I understand like where you're coming
from because you know I'm a tomboy so
yeah that's always but it's like I just
think in a relationship it's not
appropriate like I just don't think you
can like I don't think we grew up
watching our moms and the wives really
have a bunch of guy friends hanging
around doing favors for them but yeah
and like there's one day you just wake
up and realize everyone's trying to [__]
you and I'm I'm really confused how you
haven't had that like realization yet oh
I have that's the thing oh so you know
they would your guy friends not my guy
friends that's the thing that's what
that's where you're trying to turn the
you're trying to turn the story into
then it's not that that is with other
people but when it comes to but you've
had some guy friends for for a long time
and you know those dudes those
I have had guy friends in the past that
have tried to [__] me yes yes no but
these friends that hang on these friends
that I have the friends that I have
right now have never tried to [__] me
and these are friends like one of them
has been friends with me no they haven't
they won't okay and I know that for sure
but either way but now you've broken up
with your boyfriend has anyone said oh
yeah I didn't break up with my boyfriend
over that no but whatever regardless Oh
Come Around you don't I'll come for you
you know yeah they're gonna comfort you
yeah
like these are these are people came my
boyfriend doesn't pay my bills my
boyfriend doesn't live with me there's
problem number one
wait it is not my boyfriend's
responsibility to pay my bills it is not
his responsibility but if you live did
you live together no oh okay okay so you
don't live together okay that's not
really yeah we were together for two
months oh oh that's totally that's what
I'm saying okay it wasn't a mind you I
was with this person for two months yeah
I've had my friends for 10 years my
friends were there for me when I was
homeless my friends were there for me
when I got raped my friends were there
for me when I was getting divorced like
it was I was friends with them while I
was married so these are people that are
don't play with that too much
I don't even yeah mean I I can sort of I
could sort of see both sides on this
because I I know for sure I mean so
here's the thing right as a guy I don't
really I don't really have female
friends I've got a lot of women that I
know that I'm kind of friendly with you
know we'll have a bit of Atlanta blah
blah blah I'm not really I mean I was a
little bit Miami actually because I
can't with Xena or I hang out with this
girl pixie and stuff but even them
they're kind of people that are sort of
it's almost work related in a way you
know they're kind of people that I know
through these shows and all that [__]
but I'm not like there's no women in my
life at all that I'm just friends with
like oh hey guys should we go and hang
out hang out on Saturday but that's just
me that's that's my that's the way that
I operate you know my friends are guy
friends but at the same time there are
certainly women that I know that I have
zero sexual interest in and we're kind
of friendly and I know it's never gonna
I'm never gonna suddenly turn around and
go I really want to [__] her do you know
what I mean it's just not going to
happen so I do accept that you know that
there are these there can be these sort
of male female friendships but as a guy
when you're going into a relationship
with a woman I would see it I would have
some I would have concern about it yeah
I guess you don't know it and also just
just even if you're not going to [__]
them there's something about the level
of intimacy that you might have with
those dudes which is an insecurity well
which might make him
thinking
yeah almost anyone's Investments or
maybe you should invest in me first damn
well that's right that's what I was
trying to get at like that's why I was
saying yes I understand he he doesn't
need to pay all your bills but he needs
to show that he's showing enough of an
interest in you that he is number one
and you're gonna make him number one and
yeah and that's obvious and then he'll
become secure with whatever else is is
in line like make him number one and and
listen to him wait what are you gonna
say hold on hold on what are we going to
say oh I wasn't I thought you said
before he had to pay for everything but
you kind of walked back on it so no I
don't I don't no I don't necessarily
well she doesn't even yeah she's not
yeah and you're not living together it's
a different type of diet totally
different type of dynamic I thought it
was like a marriage okay what were you
gonna say you're going to say something
I was actually going to ask uh Troy a
question so do you like so I understand
because I agree I mean I was like Pearl
and like Moana like I I always grew up a
tomboy I played Sports I did a lot of
things I was like one of the guys I grew
up on a ranch and I rode dirt bikes yeah
so I was was around a bunch of dudes
that my dad trained every weekend ready
yeah so I had a lot of guy friends
because girls didn't really like me and
then we don't I didn't like the drama of
women yeah that's typical for what women
say it is true it's just true it is
because women are catty and for some
reason women are always in competition
with each other which is stupid but when
I so I had more guy friends but like
when I started dating my husband like I
that just kind of fell off and then like
I stopped talking to like my guy friends
because I'm like that's not appropriate
anymore but I understand because he
proved that to me he's like it could be
your best friend and he could be gay but
he would still want to [__] you or at
least see you naked and the problem is
like if you want to move the exact same
as a single woman as you do as a wife
and we want to give up nothing for the
man oh yeah and I give up if you didn't
like I give up everything and I have no
problem with it so but do you think that
a guy because I've had men argue with me
saying that it's not the same for men
because when we see women and we don't
we're not sexually attracted to them but
that doesn't mean that the woman doesn't
have her own intentions so do you think
that it should be equal in that aspect
like if you genuinely want to be with
this person that you should phase off
your stinger girlfriends yeah well you
mean female if anything yeah like female
friendships you should fight
um
herself like is there am I chasing this
friendship because there's a one percent
chance that I'm still looking for
something or do I really not give a
[__] word genuinely friends that's
and that's rare
there's no sexual desire like no I have
no sexual desire for this person we're
just really close like like there she's
like my sister but at the same time that
doesn't mean that you don't know if she
secretly has feelings for you for the
opportunity
for a woman that's where intuition is so
this is where our society teaches us
like drug dealers women's intuition is
the dumbest well that's where our
society
tuition was so good you'd be married
like
I said that I got divorced is so good
that she's picked a load of guys who's
cheated on you
but I want to shift gears
you know when something is wrong oh what
you said you that you had intuition that
they cheated
yeah yeah and you know my intuition was
correct yeah right but but your
intuition LED you to be in those
relationships so you picked the guys
that kept shooting I picked the guys but
that's
understanding that that's so you
understood I think women are just
dummies yeah I think we're just dumb I I
think
we are not that smart mentally but we
are smart internally we feel things more
than men do and once we die alone and
that's what makes us nurturing and once
we die likely to kill infants and Elders
that's because of our society right now
I like how nothing's ever women's fault
it's like well we killed the infants and
the elderly but where are you getting
women women actually killed women
actually killed their infants even
before the last hundred years I know
it's [__] up it's beyond fact
yeah yeah yeah
I've talked to historians about this
it's in the history of by Dr David Baker
because back when we were like you know
walking around the caveman days if you
had more than two kids it was going to
slow down the path so if you had a third
kid you would kill it and even in the
1800s lots of women killed their Cowboy
abortion is not a new phenomenon no
women women are much more violent than
men and that's actually why I came to
the conclusion that we're just kind of
idiots
yeah like we love the serial killer [__]
we've got Ted Bundy yeah I know like we
used to go to witches so that way they
can actually aboard their gym well and
then this is the thing women can be
great but it's always under the
authority of a man okay I want to shift
gears here yeah this is good this is
good I'm gonna shift over to the the
topic of monogamy oh oh [__] monogamy
bro okay so whoa okay you know let's go
one at a time I want to get your
thoughts on my topic is
my topic is this we talk about high
value men or Men of Valor or guys that
are the top one percent yeah the the
chance of them being monogamy monogamous
is what 97 of two percent one percent
that they'll be monogamous and a lot of
these women say well I wouldn't I don't
want my husband to cheat okay so they go
for this High valued man and then they
end up being with another woman and and
the responses from us is what did you
expect was going to happen and so
they're like well that's that's not a
high valued man because he cheats so I
want to get your feedback on when women
say he's not high value because he
cheated well I think it's stupid because
it's like okay you're gonna judge his
Sim you have sinned too are you not high
value is your husband not high value
because he watched porn is he like now
we're out here comparing sin and I just
think like the Trad cons will come at
this and I'm like get off your high
horse the society picks who's high value
yeah the society with that so and women
cheat first let's talk about this when
it comes to them and yes when it comes
to the monogamy contract fact we're
supposed to be virgins on our wedding
days when we have the most power we have
the most sexual agencies when we're like
21 22 that's when we have the most power
and do we pick lifelong monogamy we
don't
so it's really when you think about it
the women who are picking non-monogamy
and then they whine later when the
husband [__] a stripper one time now
he's the devil
when it's like it's like you know I
think sometimes we could come into
things with a little bit of humility no
we're not perfect either so so when it
when a guy like Kevin Sam used to say uh
high value men don't cheat they have
options yeah what are your what are your
thoughts on this I want to hear from you
well I think the whole I mean just to
what Pearl said I think this whole thing
about is somebody high value they're not
high value because they're cheated it's
bollocks to be honest we can't just we
can't just we can't just
we can't just sort of like tweak the
definition of what high value is based
on what we think is morally right or not
like if I do type value if a dude is
like I don't know man he's he's he he
has power he has a lot of people working
for me maybe he's like made a lot of
money maybe his Jacks he's whatever you
know it's it's like you said it's
Society regards it's society's decision
making he doesn't suddenly become not
high value because his exercises options
in the sexual Marketplace why the [__]
wouldn't he do that that's what high
value that's what powerful men have done
since the beginning of time I didn't
pause and I said Hitler or who's more
high value Hitler but he was faithful or
MLK but he cheated
like it's like I still want the black
guy
[Laughter]
you know what I mean it's like it's like
every person has sin and now they're
judging like that sin is so much worse
than all
contextualizing they're redefining yeah
high value means to suit their own
ethical purpose and that is but that's
what men do too about high quality women
so yes they do no high quality no
because when I asked Michael 13 when I
was on his podcast I asked him what what
to you is a traditional woman which is I
didn't ask him high value asked him what
a traditional woman was and he had 11
[__] answers from 11 different
religions and I'm like so how is that a
high value or traditional woman if you
just come up with your own [__] thing
what you also have to know how you know
but you know how he chooses to live his
life so it makes sense that he is not
sticking with one religion but if
someone else
that's what I'm saying no people used to
we used to have a very religious system
but if you want the real the real answer
the real answer is if you what is a high
value woman it's I'm sorry I'm afraid
it's a hot 23 year old you know
basically you not not to me no objective
truth is
23 not 32. exactly exactly exactly
32. I said it the reason that is is
because they can reproduce women
shouldn't vote
I can reproduce healthily
but it's not just I mean yeah for me
yeah you can say that but but for
society why is it a 123 year old girl
you can start an Instagram account get
700 000 followers yeah get set a
shitload of money get brand deals get
flown all over the world that is power
that's society's the reason she's given
those resources is because Society
regards her as high value and
unfortunately a woman who's like 30 I
don't want to say like 37 whatever it's
gonna be harder for her to do that so
that we just have to look at it's almost
like follow the money we have to look at
whose Society is saying is high value
well it is these young hot women I'm
afraid I always have a hard time
wrapping my head around that because I
actually have more options now thank you
[__]
I'm with you too but generally you're in
a small town where nobody knew where you
were no I'm talking I wasn't in a small
town when I was 23 years old okay I left
when I ate when I was 18. no how old
were you when you were married I was 24
25. okay so you got married so there was
your option no but I'm saying even out
of 23 or 21 year old or like 18 like I I
look better now than I did when I was
younger and that's what that's taking
care of you that's eating healthy here's
the thing but here here's the thing
you're more pure and innocent when
you're younger and that's also more
attractive
you might change your beauty look and
you might have a different look that
might be sexier to a point but if a guy
is like looking at a girl that's like
like you said she's 23 24 25 26 or she's
30 33 34 she's like hotter it's like no
wait a minute she's got less baggage
I heard the men
happy sex
let's see that because they're probably
thinking that the older women are a
little bit more desperate but just
because they're younger doesn't mean
that they're actually more Pure or less
I lost my virginity to my first fiance
when I was 20 years old
we're not sad like you're not the
average
it's like anecdotal like point of view
to caveat all of this I mean all you
ladies are very attractive in here today
it's not about like obviously on an
individual level there are incredibly
hot women who are in their late 30s 40s
whatever of course I'm just like if you
look at it across the board but most
girls in that age are overweight these
days too
yeah so like that's why or trans
but you could even like [__] are
still alive would you would you [__] uh
uh
yep who was previously a woman yeah
she's yes to everything
I promise you yeah but you're bisexual
though yeah
[Applause]
I would eat a snipped [__]
okay so I'm gonna switch over lizzo
we're gonna talk about lizzo about body
positivity all right he's a little high
value woman then because like no no
bottom of the barrel
she's made a lot of money though right
so that she's attracted to guys that
want to make the money off of her that
have the money but here's the point she
fired her dancers because they were too
big
yeah and she's the size of the Moon like
I don't understand that what she's a
bowling ball a bowling ball so what what
is what do you think about body
positivity now like for it's all
[__] it's all to promote negative
body image so people go oh like I I have
an extra five pounds on me this is okay
then it turns into 10 pounds then you
turn into infertile then like you're not
you're not having normal human
interaction with other people and that's
what this is all about like the old
perspective could this be to do with the
depopulation yes absolutely right
interesting absolutely
making people like when they started
when I when I was acting and I saw that
they were going from like bikini models
to uh Latin X and I didn't even know
what latinx was and all of these
different terms that made no sense I'm
like something's going on here and
progressively there are less and less
quote-unquote normal people on TV and
film and in ads and that's to promote
people not having sex with one another
and creating babies
step one under Pearl's World under my
Administration okay I'd be like women
shouldn't even be here in office but I
still have it so I'd be like let's take
away the vote and I'll step down but
step two before I left office would be
let's ban fat chicks from magazines I
was supposed to look at maggots
I was supposed to be
I was supposed to look at magazines I
used to put them on the fridge and no
I'll never look like that but I want to
try and now they have ruined that for me
for life there's all these fatties and
these average looking chicks and now we
got there like oh Victoria's Secret is
back to the hot chick you got Giselle
whatever she's like 40. she's like 40 no
it's the 18 22 year old hot chicks that
I'll never look like I'm so mad that
they took this away from me
yeah I think we need to bring back fat
shaming I personally think
well not shaming but but saying this is
you can see when somebody's healthy
versus unhealthy and that's not
necessarily skinny people are unhealthy
too you can see it though you can see it
now yeah but skinny people skinny people
have some Starbucks
no not anorexia I'm talking about like
stomach ulcers
so so heart disease is like the number
one killer I worked in a hospital for
nine years there's a lot of there's a
lot of skinny people who I'm not saying
that people who are skinnier but here's
the problem
okay everybody oh
woosah no just kidding uh but what we're
talking about is when you're overweight
you have visceral fat around your organs
right and it's dangerous and that the
health care has went up in America heart
disease is the number one killer of
people in America yeah that with the
addition of the
I won't say it but the hmm yep yeah and
now all these people are dropping dead
and I think when they're promoting an
unhealthy lifestyle it's very negative
especially for the younger women younger
men and that more and more people now
are sitting behind the computers they're
not out actively lifting changing tires
you're doing labor work which is rare
um a lot of these guys can't even change
a car tire right I do a lot of [__] that
guys can do and so here's the thing our
testosterone levels are low women's
estrogen levels are out of whack the
hormones everybody's sitting back and
what are we doing we're snacking we're
eating and our portion sizes are so big
especially in America that we are one of
the most obese countries in the world
when people come from other countries
are like the first thing the men notice
they say you guys got a lot of big
people and then they go
fat women it's amazing and so we don't
see this yeah yeah so when you travel I
don't know how many you go out of the
country you two are always in and out
these are these are like Superstars here
International do you see that I know
England's England's kind of like the US
I would say but when you go to other
countries and you're on podcasts what do
you see do you see a lot of uh you see
the same Trend everybody's getting
fatter but like we're significantly
fatter in England England you guys think
you're so much thinner you're not
I'm right
Americans are so fat I'm like okay you
guys are like five percent thinner than
us I mean I've seen Pearl's show and
they're like I'm normal I'm normal and
I'm like dude
you're like you know yeah they're like
Moby Dick over here well no I just had
all my German nannies come back a couple
turned into whales I I think the trend
is across the border so each is worse
and then Nanny watch your dog no I grew
up with like um nannies every day okay
oh
[Applause]
no
um when I had nannies every year
um from the time I was like two years
old and was an opera in America program
so they stayed for one to two years so
okay 20 plus names we just had a whole
Reunion where a bunch of them came back
yeah yeah yeah and yeah I mean a decent
amount do you think it's a colder
climate do you think it's like you know
well let's sorry here's the thing
I agree with pearl about um England I
don't think England's Great by any means
I think there's a lot of you know I
think there's a big weight problem over
there probably Western Europe to some
extent Eastern Europe is where it's at
now like before the War I was in Ukraine
quite a lot and I mean Ukraine you you
wouldn't generally speaking you wouldn't
see that many fat chicks wandering
around Romania as well I have to say I
was in Romania quite recently again you
know pretty pretty slim so the the
Eastern Eastern full Breeze Eastern
European blog that's kind of where yeah
know body mass index is better but
having said that I spent a lot of time
in Poland and in Poland now you know if
you walk around the mall you'll see
stores you'll see like plus size models
in the stores and stuff like that so
people are saying in Poland I think
that's not true though I think it's a
food well McDonald's
like and the women over they're cooking
how many people I've always been I'm
cooking bratwurst over well it's in
Germany but but let me ask you a
question how many well single gal now
but do you cook at home a lot or do you
eat out a lot or do you eat fast food
now you got a metabolism of a hamster I
mean this woman can eat anything but do
you eat out a lot uh yeah okay but
you're too transpussy
yeah
cancel again
controversial pop podcast this is the
one to come on oh this is amazing
Glenn don't call me again I don't like
that guy no question for pro it's a
little left subject a little bit okay go
ahead not really but you saying like you
know women shouldn't vote and and saying
that women shouldn't even be in office
kind of you know I get it then why
should people listen to you saying that
they shouldn't they should listen to the
man but I'm in this time period so I'm
going to keep talking no and I thought
about this actually women just have an
advantage on social media we do but when
it comes down to it Ben Shapiro who's
someone yeah you know I think he's 10
times smarter than me yeah you know the
men are always going to be smarter than
the women but yeah please most of the
time okay when they have their head on
their shoulders
if you have someone in my position that
has the same amount of subscribers as me
he's probably smarter Jordan Peterson
Ben Shapiro yeah yeah smart I like
Jordan smarter those guys
but the thing is like okay they may be
smarter but like as a woman I would
respect your opinion a little more just
because you're a woman I feel like more
safe with you why wouldn't that be a
okay
from the beginning
there's always been high IQ women in
history right so there's always been
exceptions but they don't make the rule
yeah so like for example the first
female property owner 1600s first female
millionaire
um late 1800s like there's always
there's been there's been women yeah
there's been women where like
um like men would travel to get wisdom
from but it's the exception it's not the
rule the majority of us are dummies yeah
dummies and and we can't but we can't we
can't just keep calling each other
dummies we have to teach no I can't
I know we have to teach them because
it's not going to get better if we just
keep calling them down no no I think it
would just be better if we stop giving a
[__] what women think I think that's
like the worst thing I think is caring
what women think I say take this [__]
away
allow them to to learn how to follow a
man's lead properly I gotta I gotta I
gotta divert this Coco you haven't said
a lot what are your thoughts on this uh
which one
I mean I don't I don't interrupt people
but so
right like I I do not because I've had a
lot of conversations like this with my
husband I do believe that women should
not vote because even back then it was
like the husband knew what was
appropriate and good for his family so
he had I mean I did tell him which he
did agree with me I think the only thing
that women should have a say for
something is actually regarding the
schooling of their kids not the toxicity
it is now but back then because the
mothers are taking care of the kids
they're going to the ptas because the
dads are working the dads are doing what
they need to do to provide for the
family so she's still going to
parent-teacher conferences so she should
be able to say like no honey we
shouldn't vote for this or this or this
what they want to change in the
schooling but that's it like that's it I
mean I I don't like negativity towards
people because I gave zurka a lot of
crap for that the way he spoke to people
so I don't necess I agree that women are
not the brightest today's day and age
they are very toxic but I would never
say like yeah exactly I mean I'm not
saying what she's saying is true who
gives a [__] what these women feel
because feelings is a relevant it's
about logic but I agree with
um with what she's saying that
Christian's saying that like well we
have to show them the way we need to be
there needs to be women out there that
are actually educating these women being
like hey you want to know why you're so
dumb and this [__] isn't working for you
this is the reason why this [__] isn't
working for you
to get you guys going
instead of girls going
I actually want to listen to her you
know I think I think they're actually
women respond better to social shaming
than men yeah actually like women
respond very quickly to social just
because we care about their feelings
yeah we care a lot what other people
think so I actually think negative
social shaming would be more effective I
think the last hundred years what we've
done is we've been soft and nice I'm not
saying and we come into wait wait wait
and we come into Industries and we
police the way that men talks if we do
no no I see concern I'm not saying you
but I'm saying I see conservative women
do this all the time they'll say like
there's a study that came out we're
saying that women were more liberal hmm
do you know about the teenagers the
women were more liberal what is the
first thing the women do well guys it's
how you're talking we have to talk the
way that we feel is the best way to talk
to get these young women when it's like
who gives a [__] what the idiot women
think most women are idiots when they're
16. and so it's like I agree but you're
talking to women like a man would talk
to women instead of a woman talking to
women and that's what they do you
understand do you understand the
difference and you know it's the crazy
thing is I've been more effective than
any other woman you're putting yourself
out there and because
I killed but nobody's listening to you
so why are you coming you're telling me
what is your what is your purpose uh my
purpose is objective truth I think that
we need to look for things that are true
and I need to stop caring about how we
feel and look for what is true exactly
if it's flat guys
so look I want to shift over to the
independent boss successful women and
masculinity
you're one of them you're one of them I
am [__] me that's what I'm saying I'm
not I just said I'm a piece of [__] and
I ain't worth a lot that is not I'm
saying
Okay so
yes Western culture especially in
America I am an independent boss woman
right all these women want to they I can
I can have both I said they can't have
both you can't have both one has to
sacrifice the other I can be really
successful to be a CEO of a company and
be successful in relationship or married
what are your thoughts when you're when
you're working with couples or
individuals or men dating and they want
to meet a girl that's very successful
what do you tell them yeah
your promises are all wrong
my friend James always tells the story
right so he was on the date in in Mexico
he was in Mexico in Tulum you know it's
kind of fancy yeah yeah and he was on
this day and he met he met this this
woman she was like a New York kind of
ball bustery type woman like 35 like hey
man you know like like lawyer or
whatever they want this day and on dates
he does this thing the question game
where you ask a question she's got to
answer it and then she asks a question
you know back and forth and her her
first question to him was so what was
your bottom line last year oh God and he
was just like all right
see you later so that that's the problem
with with with with those types of women
they can be very masculine very sort of
confrontational and and gray you know
but it's it's not it's not attractive or
it's not attractive right I don't think
it's dudes I think it's attractive to
some dudes because they they don't feel
they've got any options they don't
really know what's possible and they're
just like okay well this is how things
are I I accept this you know yeah but
for for most guys they don't want to
accept that kind of energy and that's
why we've got all these passport Bros
who are going over to Colombia and these
other places
um we scared them off exactly and I
think it displays femininity right
because it's way too masculine yeah it
doesn't show that a woman is actually
feminine which is what men find
attractive if the woman is their
femininity yeah and I mean I don't like
the word pure I think that's stupid like
nobody's pure no man no woman is like
pure like I mean well except for those
two except for those two little cute
guys
[Laughter]
somebody brought this up but there's and
I don't call relationships Partnerships
I hate that term that was David yeah
that was David we were talking about
that in the back oh it's feminist
language yeah get it in there oh okay
yeah cause there's no partnership yeah
it's a relationship right yeah I'm
leading the household you're following
and why do women have a problem with
this I see this all the time oh because
we're like so controlling naturally just
like yeah we just want to control
everything I got a question
how do you know I'm 26. okay I'm putting
her in the hot seat in a good way what's
your what's we need to get you married
do you think you'll get married in the
next two to three years
did you find the right guy yeah okay but
for you to find the right guy we talked
about this I know the odds are against
me I want to know what that looks like
for you that's a mindset no it's a fact
I'm gonna tell you why yeah I just like
to make jokes no but how tall are you
I'm six foot
six feet tall
okay I'm not gonna talk about her income
but I I know I'm a business guy I crunch
numbers that's what I do okay so he's
got to be over six feet tall he's got to
make a lot of freaking money okay that's
okay but she's competing with a lot of
them well she has to learn to not
compete
you want to talk about that what if you
don't compete for that yeah you have to
take the back seat that's okay
your husband I'm talking about she's
competing with a lot of women for that
one guy
um but she doesn't even have to go into
it with that mentality because she's
already proving herself in this Sabrina
she's already proving herself wouldn't
she be considered the masculine because
you're you have that like you're
powerful you're a woman who has their
own podcast
you have control over all of that
nobody asks you right I'm not coming at
you but it's like people I mean you
should see all the messages I get from
men after Shaquille on my podcast I
should have like charged them 5.99
can you tell Pearl that I'm six feet
tall
no tell me what happened I feel bad
because he was actually super nice but
it's kind of a funny story so I'm gonna
tell a time oh my God sorry if you see
this
um no I went on a date and he saw the
podcast and I and he was like oh I'll
take you on a date and I was like okay
and he was like yeah so I meet all your
requirements like let's get married
[Laughter]
so Pearl this is the intervention
[Music]
we're going to take the applications
okay okay so let's talk about your guy
go ahead ask no I'm curious like if you
had to picture like your ideal guy
um what do you think like someone like
my dad oh my God
I'm gonna pull the Jay Waller don't do
it why but are you anything like your
mom no remember what Jay Waller said and
you got you got bent out of shape before
the podcast you know I don't remember
jaywald was talking about how high value
men cheat oh yeah I may love that one
with all my heart yeah
thank you I mean you people can think
what they want but my my dad's like he's
not I'm not going there he's never had
social media but no um I find that a
winner yeah no my dad is like actually
the best person yeah he sold a
successful software company the guys
they got and then gifted the the
software company uh location oh yeah my
he gave me a building the other day
to be extremely hard for you to find a
guy it's the guy that's actually going
to genuinely love you than all the
things that you actually have to offer
so that's more of a challenge for you
you know it's funny I have a dowry I do
I come with I come with like eight acres
of land okay
my dad bought a neighborhood [__] he
put it gave us all like an acre like a
little plot that's awesome yeah so I was
thinking I was like the next podcast
about eight Acres you're coming prepared
he couldn't ask my mom he's like where's
my Dowry for taking your daughter so I'm
gonna say this if you say money he
doesn't need anything
you're not gonna respect him after a
while because you're gonna be the guy
paying you're gonna be paying for
everything okay well I really would like
to I like Engineers okay you want an
engineer six feet tall engineer I'm
taking notes for these guys so
um
ideally Catholic that's like idea
Christian's okay like Christians that's
a former Chris
okay so you want guys to like Mary okay
yeah and yes ideally like attracted to
him you know what does that look like
for you yeah like well six feet tall
engineer but do you like guys with dark
hair light hair like what do you find on
their physical features attractive do
you like to have a little bit of weight
we have the online application going up
this week we should we have to do a
podcast together absolutely are you like
a demisexual like where it's like the
personality is what gets you I feel like
that's like you I'm assuming though no
you mean
no I just don't see her being like
she hits me right now girls I am never
talking to Maverick again like she
doesn't think that she would go for like
just to get Chad like if he doesn't have
to look like a game
that's why we're doing something like
demisexual that makes it sound like like
that's is that like pansexual well you
know something about gender no it's just
about personality I feel like I mean I
don't like those words I feel like
they're nonsense I don't too but I
didn't know how to accept when a guy's
really really conservative it like gives
him a point or two if he doesn't think
women should vote I'm like oh that's hot
I don't know I like a nice smile
um black or white usually
um
yeah tall I usually like kind of like a
like like tall slender build athletic
slender I mean ideally like basketball
slender or like Wiz Khalifa or like oh
I've dated a bigger guy before so that
hasn't okay and he's got to live in the
States because you're gonna move back to
the States because I'm moving I'm taking
this data for our application yeah we
need to get this thing like pushed down
on the internet
no we're gonna we're
working no no Troy him you're gonna
filter through them and then we're gonna
have a podcast with the guy you know we
should do you should we should do all
the we should get the guys to phone in
on the podcast so we can bet them Pearl
when you relocate here to the states
yeah in Vegas you can still have your
Chicago location yeah every London you
have those rolling and then you have
here yeah you're coming here I'm not
saying no okay it's a yes you were
coming here okay we love you out here
the the you know don't go to the Midwest
or the East Coast they got value table
out there we don't need anymore okay so
uh Stateside what what else what else
are we looking for so I got
um six feet tall engineer I've gone for
guys shorter than me before that's what
I was just saying
[Laughter]
they have to be tall I'm average heights
you're not five five nine five ten five
nine is the average height you're making
fun of me it's cold outside
yeah yeah five ten okay five ten okay
okay like what's the difference between
five ten and six five like right there
yeah
when you put your heels on there's a
there yeah when I wear heels I'm taller
than that I'm just so used to it okay I
just have to have baskets do they have
to have basketball skills no okay no she
takes guys on basketball dates well I
love
proful or not when I say high profile
like known would you prefer that would
you actually prefer somebody who's not
known I've actually been thinking about
this and because I at first I was like
maybe it's easier to like date someone
that like is doing what you do but I
think I've concluded that it might be
easier if he just doesn't care about
this stuff
um
he might have to work remote right
because he's going to travel with you
right well I figured like I wouldn't
travel as much when I like moved to the
U.S like people would come to me oh they
will everybody comes here Patrick Davis
Patrick Davis here today actually Adam's
here well I actually Adam and David are
here today well I actually didn't
um
what did I say I didn't
I'm not sure I'm going to Chicago
anymore so it's on the table maybe Vegas
[Music]
my new shirt is Pearl I can't make her
own decision I can
that's kind of what's gonna happen
because right now I'm getting the
management because I really just I I
don't think Management's for like women
especially not me look so I'm gonna say
this I'm gonna say I'm gonna say this
you ready for this another one DJ Khaled
of the industry is Glenn Lawrence DJ her
husband this one I know we we
okay yeah but like me and you were busy
and you're way busier than me yeah in
this world but I'm not a planner and if
it wasn't for Glenn this wouldn't have
happened this wouldn't have happened
yeah I love this guy watch his stuff
right yeah but it's like you know how it
is hey you want to come on my podcast
who's this uh Puerto Rican looking dude
that's black and white right or whatever
so the point is is Glenn handles all
that and I got to give the guy props
because nobody gives him any love yeah
he works with Rollo he works with me he
works with uh uh those other guys that
the iron disciples that came in here
another guy uh Thor's coming yeah
Charlie McGill um I just have fours
coming in here tomorrow yeah he was
going to have uh berserk azerka on on
Sunday here but he's the guy no he's
just a kind person too like he spent
time with me to like teach me certain
Concepts about like red pill stuff I
didn't understand and like he's just a
really kind person and and the thing is
is you know I think with him and the
love and the cherish in the moment yeah
feel you need to be here okay go back go
back to what you were saying Vegas come
to Vegas Vegas
no I was just well she's answered the
question now I was just wondering any
questions for her on what uh the
categories for me and try to put an
application together for the guy since
you know what she needs in a man dick
size
does that matter
no okay
so you
Sports you did volleyball right so is
there anything in particular that you
find very attractive that you guys could
do like shared together as far as like
activities like do you want them to be
outgoing or like Outdoors you do like
camping like is there something like I
would really think of people if he did
this together you like to act homeless
and go camping that doesn't mean you're
acting you know that's funny I don't
camp but when I was a kid like as an
example when I was a kid we used to do a
lot of like outdoorsy stuff as like a
family and I didn't really like I did
enjoy that but I didn't have a strong
opinion either way this thing is there
an activity that you would like that you
guys could share together it could be
cool if like you do volleyball he's like
it'd be cool if he did volleyball
because then we could go like play
volleyball together I don't know it'd be
a plus to be playing so what's the
biggest turn off on a guy for you
that makes it even funnier
like I don't know I just grew up in a
family where we really like value work
ethic and I I know it's like um like I
know they like put it as like a gold
digging thing or whatever but like I
don't know my dad just really taught us
to like work hard and I'd really like a
guy that I could just like kind of as a
plan for his life and like could lead me
I guess like I love going on a date when
I just feel like he's like wise I guess
I know it's like a weird it's like a
feeling but so and and when you when you
when you have decide to have children
you don't have to slow down because
everybody comes here you so you don't
have to travel right because that's a
big thing right because because in a lot
of places you'd have to like stop doing
this just do it well I think I'll
probably like I I'd imagine with kids
like especially when they're babies like
you just slow down have you brought your
dog on the podcast yet like I told you
how does that do that did good I had a
reaction video yeah I told you yeah
we'll die I said bring her bring her on
the show yeah and then she goes I don't
know I said do it Dexter's my little
co-host oh your dog is so cute so so
before I end I want to ask a couple
questions so what's next for you where
are you going what what's going on you
got you got a website that people can go
to to get training and coaching from you
yes like do you have a book as well I'd
go yeah it's like a real Troy
francis.com they can get all the
information there I've got a bunch of
books send me the link I'll put it in my
description I will do thank you uh I've
got a bunch of books called Renegade
dating blueprint which is a collection
of different books that I've written
over the last few years about all of
this stuff and you did it without AI he
wrote the books without AI 100 but it's
all going to be AI now you wrote books
about relationships no no I'm not
qualified in there oh what did you write
a book about dating
I'm working on a new one which the
working title is the art of rizz
I'm still sort of thinking about this
because rizz is a term that a lot of
Zoomers use but it started to get kind
of quite a lot of it means Charisma like
Rays you know like a square reflex I
never heard this thing
that's the problem and that's the
problem because a lot of my audience you
know a lot like the audience I'm
catering to us you're a gentleman you
know so I'm wondering if it's gonna
alienate people but I really like the
word I think it's a really good word so
it'll work with the young crowd for sure
if it doesn't work you can just switch
Yeah Yeah uh Joker talks about rizz a
lot okay
but anyway so doing that and um yeah go
to New York City uh about the weekends
which should be fun don't go liberal
absolutely don't worry
um and then back to the UK and then
later in the year I'm doing a boot camp
training event in Colombia
um towards the other Columbia so if guys
were interested in that they can email
me
what are you doing here they're all hot
what about you what's next on the agenda
other than moving to Vegas
um right now I'm basically putting
together like a management team
so nice yes I like it I like it that's
like my basically so I can have a bit
more of like a life and like right
family and like that sort of thing sure
sure so I'm getting like a management
team and we're gonna basically do like a
network that and yeah it's gonna be
pretty cool like oh like we talked about
in other podcasts about a brand Network
yeah yeah well we just switched the
names called The Audacity Network
because we have the audacity yeah
you know nice it's gonna be a network
because I'm raunchy bro I might need to
be on YouTube
[Laughter]
video off of my debate oh yeah yeah I'm
sorry everybody's texting me do you see
what Pearl said I'm like did she say
something bad about me no no you didn't
so I got her Glenn her husband text me
and everybody started sending a message
and and the studio saw it and they're
like oh I'm sure Christina saw it so I'm
sure she's happy about it that was good
though yeah yeah know so she's um talent
in London we're gonna look for like
three four more and then do ones the
question are you still doing the divorce
documentary yes okay so when when can we
look for that uh I think it's gonna take
a bit of time just with the moves we're
probably gonna take another six months
to a year I think yeah so she's doing a
divorce documentary on divorce and and
uh maybe you can speak to that a little
bit Yeah so
um I wanted to know why men couldn't
didn't want to get married I was like
all these guys are whining about
marriage and I want to know like why I
think I'm amazing I was like why aren't
they why aren't the women I I think
we're all amazing and then I went to
this red pill journey and I was like oh
my God from a historical point of view
we're actually horrible and then I
started looking at the divorce laws and
I was like wow we're paid to leave we're
paid to take the kids we have actually
um divorce policies that discriminate
against men it's very easy to falsely
accuse a man of rape yeah of sexual
assault all that [__] and their kids
correct yeah and you know now we're in a
society that I argue actively
discriminates against men and oppresses
men wow and um yeah that's all going to
be in my documentary I love us I love it
can I tell you something kind of us way
off subject did you know that June is
men's mental health month awareness
month but but gay people take over yeah
yeah yeah gay pride yeah and that's the
thing like men are so needed Society
like men pay the majority of the taxes
they are the majority of the
infrastructure they do all the hard jobs
and it's like as a thank you now we have
these discriminatory systems that [__]
on them yeah and I think we need fathers
in the home I think fathers raise better
uh kids than mothers by themselves so
it's like I think it's really sad and
the kids are really the ones who suffer
the most yeah I think the divorce
situation is a disaster though I mean
sorry I think the divorce situation is
deserved I mean that's why I personally
would not want to get married in the UK
I wouldn't want to get married in
America I wouldn't want to get married
in the west at all well that's why I say
get it and maybe not
what marriage is under God's eyes and
value is you're taking a vow to God and
you're getting married and you're going
through the ceremony that doesn't mean
so the point is is You're Nobody God
doesn't say you need a contract that's
not government yeah but if you're from
Nevada there's no common law marriage
here in this state oh okay so where are
the where the so you could just study
living we're the Republic United States
the Republic right so every state has
like its own country so in Nevada if I
go with my girlfriend and we say let's
go take the vows we'll have a priest or
a pastor Marius under God as a witness
but I'm not signing the contract I'm
good and I can put her in I can put her
in a confidential marriage yeah and I
can put her in like some type of uh
trust that says hey if something happens
you know you're not going to be on the
street but I'm not going to have you rip
my clothes off and throw me to the
wolves and get a shitty apartment take
the kids and all this stuff the kids are
the different thing that's so that's the
state so there is a solution for IT Coco
what do you got coming down the road you
started Coco started her new podcast
right it's on YouTube it started a while
ago but it was like very slow moving
just because like you know my husband is
very busy like he's my producer and my
editor so he's managing everybody else's
life and their career so like you got
Trey Trey is the number one editor my
son he edits all the YouTube videos here
so he's in the back there you go
I got topics he's helping me plan
through those but mainly just trying to
work on that but he's going to want to
work on that a bit more like once we
open up that new studio so then that way
I can actually go there and record and
he'll have time to do it because he's
planning everybody I think it'd be good
like if if Pearl gets here and she's
doing a podcast and you're starting
yours or you're it's been going but
you're trying to kick it up it's come on
tour podcast which she has guests she
brings a real Dynamic and for some
reason a lot of Moby Dicks end up on her
podcast and so she gets them going uh no
but seriously like this and this I don't
want to say women empowerment right but
I'm saying the empowerment of of us
uplifting and changing the way people
think and building this network that
she's creating
um Glenn's creating I'm creating your
creative it's good to have a good
Network work out here oh I totally agree
with that I mean he works very hard I'm
very proud of him like he works hard so
besides trying to navigate that I'm
literally just assisting my husband and
everything that he needs because we both
worked in production so whatever he
needs that I can help him take off of
his play to make his life easier like
I'm basically like his personal
assistant so whenever he needs something
whether it's like me doing my duties as
a wife and around the house I'm taking
care of him and then just going to the
gym because I want to compete next year
which you already know that yeah so
she's I turned her on to my girls coach
okay because my girl is cut and wait
like no tomorrow so she's on this
mission for November since the time
you've seen her she's dropped pounds and
now she's trying to get leaner but yeah
so and then McGill works out with her
coach Rolo's been to the gym we're all
in the same gym too you know um so
Miguel Miguel's working out with her
coach you know I'm trying to get Charlie
and the Charlie get to the gym so but no
Lana laughing with Lana what's going on
with you you got your podcast
of comic I do stand-up comedy I do um
it's a small place out here in Vegas
called
um Mariposa that's where that's where
I've been performing Mariposa and
medinas I've been performing there doing
stand up and then my laughing with Lana
podcast you guys can find me on
YouTube's Rumble Spotify Apple podcast
it's spicy it's [__] I'm raunchy I'm
really [__] raunchy I'm not uh uh I
just say everything that's on my mind is
I was what I say and you have a and
we'll have you people go to your
Instagram as well so yeah yeah and so
Lana cherries comedy there you go hey I
appreciate everybody coming out and and
definitely thank you again I mean it was
great to meet you I would like I said if
it wasn't for Glenn I didn't even know
you're here nobody I'm I'm like the I'm
like this sorry I'm the redheaded step
child but it's like it's like we all
went to dinner
oh you know what I'm saying Adam's here
oh I didn't know that and then I got an
email from Adam's team right that's what
you need the team like they oh
Davis are here they're here and no and
like everybody say oh you know they're
here I'm like nobody told me I don't
even know they're here right so Adam
Adam's gonna I'm trying to get Adam on
tomorrow he's gonna either tomorrow
Saturday Sunday okay he's here uh his
team uh messaged me emailed me they said
he wants to get on your podcast but I I
mean if you're around I think have you
been on his podcast at all Adam sosnick
yeah I've been on value I've never been
on Patrick Matt Davis no no but but he's
so John is meeting with Patrick about
David tonight
so we need to kind of that's what I'm
talking about cool Glenn we need a guy
like Glenn to kind of bring everybody
because nobody's talking is going wait
who did you think John the owner of the
studio here oh I see you see what I'm
saying but it's all these disconnects
like he he I've seen him he didn't know
who he was you were here it's like oh
great get him on oh wait Adam's here I
didn't know Adam's here yeah and that
one guy that Glenn can kind of bring
everybody together and say hey they're
going to be in town why don't we get you
set up with all these people right yeah
I was on Valentine the other last week
actually just message on him yeah
because I didn't I was supposed to be
there August 17th but my mom has
something going on so I can leave but
I'm gonna go out there at the end of
September so yeah anyways um you're
gonna you're getting that bottle by the
way there you go there you go there's
your bottle okay I'll send you the
ingredients it's a nootropics focus HP
Alpha high value Alpha High valued Alpha
HP Alpha it competes against Alpha Brain
Joe Rogan's brand and it's a nootropics
that helps you focus as a cog supplement
I I got other supplement coming yeah I
need it because I'm ADHD kid I'm like
purple squirrel anyways thank you guys
for coming out and remember please
subscribe to this channel I need
everybody that's watching this I need
you to hit the bell for notifications we
constantly get Shadow banned and you're
not going to get notifications of our
videos on YouTube unless you hit the
bell for notifications like this video
share this video stay strong and
remember we're the number one podcast
right now in Vegas where the truth will
set you free peace out
foreign